foreign
let's go to Frank in Pittsburgh what's
up Frank
how you doing John thanks for taking my
call and thanks for everything you guys
do you got it my brother what's up dude
how can I help my question is I got I
had a baby just under two months ago
okay congratulations boy or girl thank
you boy all right little little Joseph
little Joseph
and now it's time for his his shots to
come up because his vaccines and all
that and I'm struggling trying to
trust where the CDC and all that where
where the the mistrust with covid came
now I'm struggling to to trust where the
old stuff you know I'm questioning
everything of course when you ask a
question if the doctor shut you down and
say you know it's safe just do it yeah
well do I know it's safe do I what do I
do you know do I do I listen to them or
you know I'm not an anti-vaxxer by any
means but I'm
but the whole thing got sideways yeah
the whole thing goes sideways I I've uh
I've told some of my closest friends I
think I think this was a hundred year I
maybe even still in the show I think
this was a hundred year setback
for for so we lost trust in our churches
we lost trust in our educational
institutions we lost trust in medicine
and those are pillars that prop up a
civilization and there's going to be a
long
Hard Road back to trust and
reestablishing Trust
um so I'm gonna
I'm not a vaccine expert okay
and
I am though gonna tell you how I make
these kind of decisions I'll give you a
matrix okay okay or not really not
really Matrix that's that's not right
I'm gonna give you a framework for how I
make these decisions okay okay and then
I'll tell you I'll give you like the the
nitty-gritty what I think okay which
that might buy you a cup of coffee
um if the copy is free and it's like you
know I mean so
um
big picture
there's this
um a terrible human being and you've if
you've listened to show enough you know
that I rarely say that okay I think
people are flawed they screw up we all
do and then we all have roads to
Redemption there's a terrible human
being his name is uh Andrew Wakefield
he is the fraudulent scientist
Absolute Total fraud
who came up with this bull crap
connection between the MMR vaccines and
autism
absolute fake data lied about the whole
thing and then spread it out and then
went on a on a campaign essentially him
and an attorney there's a fantastic book
by Brian dear
um it's like The Man Who tricked uh
Doctor Who fooled the world
um it's it's just disturbing okay so we
have this emergence
um recently of this anti-vaxing stuff I
can't express it enough how nonsensical
it is and here's where it's evil there
are
countless parents who have autism who
think they did something wrong to their
kid
that's why this dude is evil and that
planted these seeds of doubt and all of
us I've got two little kids right and so
I start questioning like when the I call
her the nurse of death when you have
this sweet little two-year-old or two
month old and then this sweet nurse
comes in and just pulls these these
these these shots out and Jabs this
little I mean that's a whole other day
another story okay so I want to say this
like unequivocally this is not me like
I'm making a stand no I just look at
data just pure numbers vaccines have
saved millions and millions and millions
and millions of Lives full stop period
end of sentence okay and
covid got politicized in sideways in the
covert vaccine became a nightmare
yes okay
and I am right there with you I'm right
there with you so as a new dad you're
right to be nervous like what do I do
man do I do that like you are right on
with every other dad me included okay
yep and here is the framework by which I
make these decisions this is how I make
medical decisions this is how I make
financial decisions this is how I make
mechanic decisions
number one I have one two three four
five people that work in that field that
I trust
okay now
I'm privileged in that I've worked in
universities forever I know I I can call
research scientists in my cell phone
number okay I'm in my cell phone so not
everybody's got that
um and here's the here's the question
that shifted for me about a decade ago I
do not ask people what they think
I worked at a law school and there was
some of the most Brilliant Minds in the
world and those they were legal Scholars
they were professors of law so they were
trained over years and years and years
to find arguments and exploit holes and
arguments they were Masters at it okay
and I could ask him what do you think
about something and they could spin me
an hour-long detail about it
but then I would see their kids and I
was like well your kids doing that
like do you what do you think about
organic cotton and they'd be like well I
think organic cotton is this and this
and they would give me all this data
about the fields and about Roundup and
about all this stuff and I'd see their
kids wearing cotton cotton shirts and
they'd be like oh you think this but you
believe this
yes and so I quit asking what do you
think I do not ask that question anymore
I only asked this question what are you
doing with your kids
I asked my doctor that
I ask my friends that I ask my finance
person that I told my finance person I
want my portfolio to exactly match yours
and he was like he's a close friend he's
like well you know I was like no no I
went to exactly match yours and he's
like you got it
and because if you trusted enough for
yours you're not gonna sell me some
product I want it to look just like
yours same with a car hey which car do
you think is good
well I'm I like this one but on what car
did you buy for you and your family well
we bought that one well that's what you
believe then that makes sense so with my
doctors I have asked them point blank
what did you do with your kids
and if they gave this kid that vaccine
then it's safe enough for their kid then
I don't know enough other than what the
news tells me of some stupid YouTube
videos which
should not exist so I'm going to ask the
people in the field what are you doing
with your children and that's gonna be
that's gonna be my God you see what I'm
saying yes and that has given me
a lot of peace
yep okay
and so I've given I've given my kids not
all the vaccines but I have given my
kids MMR I've given them HPV my my
oldest like I've given them those things
um and there's a few vaccines that I
didn't give
because I sat down my doctor and we
looked at the data and my doctor happens
to be a super nerd and he loves those
kind of questions I have a gut reaction
to professionals who don't like
questions
that's the the pickle I'm in is is my
pediatrician now
the practice they're in there anytime
you ask a question that's that's oh no
that's not going to happen well how do
you know how do you where's the data
where's the where do you how do you know
I mean do you
and then they they just they more blow
it off than answer the question right
and I'm fortunate
um Gus Vickery my doctor uh he he'll
he'll email me the study
and I was challenging him on something
he sent me two or three studies and I
was like well you're right and so not
every doctor can do that
um and not every doctor will do that
here's what I would love you to get in
the habit of doing and this is gonna
this is gonna be when you have to talk
to a third grade teacher this is going
to be when you talk to a middle school
coach when you whatever the theater
teacher
is sitting down and saying hey can you
explain this to me how this works
okay um and take the humble
um submission approach not the I was
watching this YouTube video and I
Googled it and I think it's because the
doctors get that all day long
yes but if you said Hey sir I feel like
you're blowing me off can I just ask you
like this is the most important this
person in my life is my little baby
I don't understand I'm getting a lot of
conflicting advice can you point me to
some data
and go from there and if they say we
don't do that then I would be on the
lookout for a new pediatrician and I
know that's a what is my insurance going
to take and it's going to take me a year
and all that I get that and that stinks
and it might not be this time but it
might be next time but
um that's where I would head out I just
might from my mechanic hey why are we
doing this particular thing and why are
we doing that I want people to explain
stuff to me and I and that's not out of
bounds if I'm paying you
exactly
yep
you're not crazy
um and you're a good dad here let me
leave you with this I'll leave you this
okay the mark of a wise person is
somebody who can hold
different
um data points in either hand and not go
mad
okay still make a wise choice
and so on the one hand we have to hold
that vaccines have saved millions and
millions of lives and if you're like I
don't think so
I promise my garden is bigger than yours
and my family eats organic I'm all into
all the conspiracies I'm just looking at
the data okay and then on the other hand
the coven vaccine turned into a absolute
Quagmire
yes okay I've got to hold both of those
and then look at my two two-month-old
and the Doctor Who wants to give them
their MMR shots round one
and say did you give these shots to your
kids because I'm just nervous about
vaccines now with all the drama
um did you give these tears and if they
look at you and say I'm not telling you
that information then say I'm I
appreciate your time I'm gonna go find
me another doctor
99 of the time they will say
yeah I did I'll leave you I think I've
told this on the show
my uh
when my uh daughter was born we had an
amazing uh the greatest OB GYN ever
she's just stunning she was ahead of the
clinic at the university hospital where
my daughter was born she just amazing
and I worked at the at the University in
another another college and so we would
I could email back and forth just
because we were in the internal system
so I would ask this kind of question and
this question and that question I was
always asking all these questions about
MTHFR and all these things
and then one day we're just doing a
routine checkup and I had just read this
thing about DEET how DEET was a
neurotoxin was going to kill us all blah
blah
yeah Deaton bug spray and we were
walking out of the OB GYN
of the you know the baby checkup and I
turned her name was Dr Phi Jennifer
fudge she's extraordinary I looked at
her and said hey
real quick
you put bug spray on your kids
and she smiled real big she knew she's
like yes John deed is not good for it's
not great
and I'm way more worried about other
things so yes I I spray bug spray on my
kids and I was like that's all I need to
know there's not one thing on a YouTube
video that I'm Gonna Learn that's gonna
be more value to me than a brilliant
research medical doctor and the way she
treats her own kids and so that that
became the litmus test for me
um I'm gonna ask you what do you do with
your kids what are you doing with your
money with your cars with your home are
you buying a house right now are you
waiting oh it's all coming down you
shouldn't buy a house why you buy one
why'd you buy one last month I mean it's
it's fine
what are you doing
with your most most important loves what
are you doing with your most important
assets that's where I'm gonna follow not
just some I think that hey and by the
way Frank you're a great dad good for
you for asking these hard questions good
for you for caring about
um the things that go in and out of your
um thank you for thinking caring about
your kid and their medical decisions
their nutrition decisions all that
you're a good man